okay
hi this is luna from amazon it's my
great honor to speak here
about our project service where
sorry where the goal is to harvest
knowledge from semi-structured web
so here i'm putting a picture of the
goddess
cyrus and this is a roman goddess
and she is taking in charge of the
harvesting
and interestingly the internal name for
this project at amazon
is the name of another goddess of
exactly the same responsibility
but different nationality
okay so before i talk about
cerris let me give you some context
about who we are what we are doing and
why we do this project so at amazon we
are building a product knowledge graph
and the goal here is to build
an authoritative knowledge graph for all
of the products in the world
such that we can use it to answer any
question about products and
related knowledge in the world and with
this comprehensive
and authoritative knowledge we will be
able to
improve amazon search recommendation
and also voice shopping
let me see okay so let me first
start with giving you a small example of
knowledge graph
for two songs so it is a knowledge graph
so it is graph and has nose and
edges each node here represents an
entity
and an entity could belong to one or
multiple different
types and each edge represents the
relationship
between two entities for example here
is a recording entity and
it is related to this entity which
is a genre and also related to
this entity which is a person
and the relationship here is artist
and the person has named taylor swift
taylor allison swift and we see the date
of birth
now let's squeeze this knowledge graph
to one side
and try to see what is the product side
so
each sound recording is
related to multiple songs
soundtracks at amazon so those song
tracks
they could have a different formats
and they belong to different albums so
that's
the product part normally when we talk
about
media products we actually have a lot of
data
on the web from publishers the media
publishers book publishers
movie publishers they are very well
trained
to provide a lot of metadata such as
the director actor artist
release date release country lens and so
on
and these are a lot of data with
decent quality
then the challenge here is different
publishers they will use
different format they will follow
different schema one source
might call it director and the other one
might call it directed by
and so the heterogeneity of the data
is what we need to resolve such that
in the knowledge graph we could have one
id for
one entity one person and we could have
one relationship
to represent the particular relationship
between two types of entities
and to resolve the heterogeneity one of
the most
important techniques is entity linkage
in other words we need to figure out
that
alison swift and uh taylor allison swift
and
taylor swift these are actually the same
person
and in addition if you want to be cool
you want to also figure out that
if we see conflicting information from
different sources
what could be the correct value for
example if we see
uh different data bursts for taylor
swift from different
sources we need to figure out which one
is correct
or is this unique and talented
lady born twice
and after that if you want to be sexy
you want to extract
knowledge from the web this is because
there could be a lot of songs
a lot of books and on the web we can
find
comprehensive information about all of
the different
choices and that's where we collect
information about
torso and even long tail books songs
movies and so on
so in our team we have developed the
entity linkage
technique that could reach precision of
99
with over 90 percent of recall and
in addition we developed web extraction
techniques
that gives us over 90 percent of
preceding
and we are applying these techniques
to collect knowledge from the web we use
it to support
20 amazon music applications we use it
to
answer questions from for alexa
so so far we have been looking at media
products
the next example is about pro
retail products and here i'm showing you
two examples uh with uh
for tight detergents so those are the
two brown bubbles
and then we have the green bubbles
represent
the variations of the same product
so they are the same product but have
different size
or maybe different scent
and in addition we have those blue
bubbles
representing the properties
of those products for example they have
same brand
tight and they have the same function
detergent
they are of the same form liquid neither
of them
is high efficiency and we can see that
the tide detergent on the left hand side
it has one extra function odor remover
so for retail products again we still
have a lot of data
from manufacturers from retail websites
but this time the data is of different
quality and to show you one example
here is a product chocolate
gift box this is from amazon
page and we see that we have very
limited
structured information about it mostly
we have is just in the title
some of them we have bullets and the
descriptions
but those are just the text information
we don't have that much of structured
information
and on the right hand side we do see
different
flavors different sizes however
how many people would consider one pound
red rose box
as the flavor of your chocolate and how
many people will consider dark blue
foils as the size of this um
chocolate box and this is mainly because
the information could be provided by the
retailers
to for some particular purposes and here
it is to show the different
variety and so it is kind of an abuse
of the attribute flavor and size
so the data here could be very sparse
and
noisy and we can do the same thing by
getting the data
from everyone everywhere and putting it
together
but garbage in garbage out so we need to
first
do something before we integrate data
from different
sources so the key technique here is
getting data from the catalog no matter
which catalog we want to first
apply data imputation we want to extract
the structured data
out of the unstructured titles
descriptions
bullets and after that we want to clean
it up
such that we can remove the noisy
information
and only keep the correct
information so in our team
we developed the system called autonomo
we increased the coverage of the
structured
data for products by 12 12
times um at amazon catalog
and also improved the accuracy by eight
percent
so the information is live on
alexa shopping amazon search and amazon
detail page
in this talk there are a lot of
techniques we have developed
but we will focus on the web extraction
part
and as i said this is the sexy part
and also one of the most challenging
part
so for our web extraction we focus
on one particular type of websites
we call it semi-structured websites let
me first
show you several examples and
here is i'm db and
i guess a lot of you are familiar with
it
you can see for a movie you can see the
movie lunch the genre
the release date release country also
you can see
some brief description the director
writer stars
and it's not a big chunk of text
or article but much more of just uh
basic facts about the movie and
put into particular formats
here is another example and this is
about a famous
indian movie and here is another example
about a famous chinese movie and they
all share the similarity
not that much of text but a lot of
factual information
about the movies
so why do we consider semi-structured
websites
and this is because according to some
previous
projects uh we can see big promise
out of it and that is the project
knowledge about
that i was involved in when i worked for
google
where our goal is to extract knowledge
from the web and we consider four types
of
web content um the one is our
text and these are the articles news
that we are all familiar with
the second one we call it dom trees and
this
is the semi-structured data we have just
the same
the third one is web tables these are
the tabular information
on the web pages and the last one is web
annotations
which is the annotations on the html
code
according to some particular ontologies
such as schema.org
so here for each type we can see the
numbers in the parenthesis
that's the number of knowledge
facts or knowledge triples extracted
from each type of web contents
and we can see that from the
semi-structured websites we
extracted eighty percent of all of the
knowledge that we
extracted in addition we also see the
overlapping triples
uh between different types of contents
and again uh with this like a huge chunk
of
triples uh the overlap is actually not
that high with other type of
web contents and we see this
much of um extractions from
semi-structured data this is not
surprising because
oftentimes those websites have huge web
huge databases underlying it
and then it use some particular template
to populate
each web page and the data are from the
database
so that's where we can find a lot of
factual knowledge
about uh real world and
another thing is um knowledge vote
has shown the accuracy of extraction
from
each type of web content for
texts the accuracy is about fifty
percent
this is six years ago uh it is not high
and for uh semi-structured websites it's
still not high sixty percent
but it is higher than web texts that
also shows some of the hope
okay so let's see what are the
opportunities
from the semi-structured data and here i
want to
use the largest iceberg
in the world as a metaphor
so if we look at a webpage about
this movie when harry met
sally from rotten tomato we can see
a lot of information for those
attributes that we are familiar with
such as genre directed by written by
and these are the attributes
already uh modeled uh in the
free-based ontology so freebase is one
of the
largest free knowledge graph and
this is corresponding to the part of the
iceberg that is
above the water so we know those
relationships
in addition we have attributes that
existing ontology may not
capture such as in theaters on disk
streamlining and so on and we did some
analysis
we looked at 10 semi-structured movie
websites
and we found the imdb ontology which is
actually a very comprehensive
ontology it covers only seven percent
of the relations and that
could be considered as the part of the
iceberg that is below the water
in addition we also have a lot of
domains that we are not familiar with
we know movies but we may not know that
much
about broadway shows we may not know
that much about
um video games and we can consider that
part
as the part of the iceberg that is deep
in the water so we can see that
semi-structured data
can give us information about
the known uh relations
the unknown relations and also the
unknown domains
that's why we are saying it is really
really a huge source of information
and very promising
okay so where are we in terms of
extracting knowledge
from semi-structured websites well
we are at the tip so
our current technologies still heavily
rely
on manual annotations and with the
manual
annotations we are able to achieve a
precision over 95 percent
very good however
these are oftentimes about existing
schemas from
existing domains and we see high quality
oftentimes only on those easy attributes
where there is a single value such as
date of birth
when there are multiple values such as
multiple actors of a movie
we don't see this very high quality
anymore
and if we want to do automatic
extraction
again according to knowledge what the
precision is still
quite low 63 percent that's far away
from being able to get into production
in industry
so why is it so hard let's see
what are the main challenges for
extracting knowledge from
semi-structured web
the first one is even though we see a
lot of similarity of the web pages from
the same website
the format can actually vary slightly
on different web pages so here are two
imdb web webpages and we see that
even though it looks very similar but on
the left page we have director writer in
the stars
and on the right one we have only
director and the stars
and we do not have writer information
possibly because we don't have that
information in the database in the
underlying database
and then the next challenge which is a
much bigger challenge
is that different websites the data are
formatted
totally differently and here are the
three examples we saw
and they look so different it's very
hard to imagine we can train one model
to collect information from all of these
sources
so a natural thought when you see this
is that
okay let me train one
model per website but the next
question is to do such training how can
we collect
the training data it's almost impossible
to manually collect
training data for each predicate on each
website
just because there are so many
okay so can we get
the whole iceberg to answer this
question
let's first see with all of the
challenges
what are the opportunities what are the
kind of
clues that we could leverage
to extract knowledge from
semi-structured websites
so i would say the first clue is the
site-wide commonality and
if we look at these two pages from imdb
and also the previous examples as well
we can see there are a lot of
commonalities
and in fact if we look at the html code
behind it
they are populated using the same
template and by the way
for the html code uh it is structured
in some dom trees we will uh refer to
this concept
so it has a whole bunch of nodes nested
um within um each other
and so give the structure of this um
dom tree so previous work
have leveraged this commonality between
the web pages within the same website
there are two major streams of work one
is a wrapper induction and here
the idea is that since those
html files are so similar
let's get manual annotation for a few
pages maybe five pages maybe 10 pages
and then we could reverse engineer
what are the dom paths to generate
particular predicate information such as
the board date
and with such manual annotation we are
able to
achieve precedent above 95 percent
and but again as i said before it is
typically
on easy attributes with a single
value another thread
is relation extraction so the idea there
is when i look at the html code
let me just treat it as normal text
and then i could apply the same text
techniques for relation extraction on
normal text
so we will apply distance supervision to
generate the training data
and when we found two entities somewhere
on the page
we will look it up on the website
sorry on the knowledge graph and then
decide
what is the relationship in the
knowledge graph
and accordingly guess the relationship
on this website in this way we can
generate a whole bunch of training data
and use it to train the model per
website so the quality
for that training data is actually very
low
because there are a lot of entities on
each page and so
a lot of noises a lot of wrong guests as
a result
the extraction procedure is still low
only 60 percent
so we built this system called ceres
which is also doing automatic
extraction it is different from the
previous technique
in two parts the first one is we do
two stage extraction instead of looking
at
every pair of entities on a page we will
first
find out what is the topic of each page
for example on this web page it is
alfred
and on this web page it is viola
and after we decide the uh topic
in other words that will be the subject
of all of the extracted triples from
this page
we then find the attribute value pairs
for this subject
so the second difference is that
we are leveraging the site-wide global
information when we generate the
training data
even in distance supervision in training
data generation we already
explore the similarity across the
different web pages
so for example here we have worn we have
diet
it may not be easy to distinguish them
but we know
born should have similar template
similar paths on each page and that's
where we will guess
hey this is the boring relationship
together with
all of the information from the
knowledge graph
so that will help us to generate higher
quality training data
with that we are able to improve the
precision
from 63 percent to over 90 percent
to give you more um details
so we applied this method
on the swd benchmark data
the benchmark contains four different
domains
and for each domain it has 10 websites
and we applied our method on this 40
websites
comparing it with the previous wrapper
induction work
so we can see that we get very high
precision
and in addition if we compare the f
material we get
for our method and the f measure from
wrapper induction based on
annotations we get quite uh comparable
f measure except on books because on
books we have
very very little see the data in our
knowledge graph so we are not able to
generate too many
uh training labels
we applied the same techniques on 33
websites those are long tail movie
websites
and it contains english and six
other languages it also contains a lot
of long tail movies such as animated
films documentary films
and in total we have 400 000 web pages
crowd by common crowd so we are able to
automatically annotate
16 percent of the pages for each
page we annotate we are able to extract
from 2.6 pages in other words
we add 1.6 entities
and for each triple we annotate we are
able
to extract three triples or in other
words we add
two more triples and in total we get
1.25 millions of extractions with
precision 90
so this figure
shows the precision and the yield curve
as we change the confidence threshold
we see the precision will go up and
certainly the yield will go down
and at this point annotated by this
vertical yellow line our precision is 90
and we get about 1.25 millions of
triples
so so far we are able to take care of
the part of the iceberg above the water
so
we are able to extract on those
attributes that we already modeled in
our ontology
okay so that's the first clue
the next clue is the layout on the page
so here is a page for this movie and
we know let's say uh the information
about the genre directed by
written by according to our current
knowledge graph
and then just by looking at the
vertical and horizontal alignment we are
able to guess
something else first because in theaters
is vertically aligned with these three
attributes
so this is likely to be another
attribute
and the second because this july 12
is horizontally aligned with in theaters
and so this is likely to be the value
for it
so by exploring this intuition
we developed open service which allows
us
to apply open information extraction
such that we extract those attribute
words
as the attribute and so we can
extract knowledge for those new
attributes
so we applied weak learning we
generate training data for existing
attributes as what we did before
and then we look at the
page layout and identify uh
potential new attributes and we do this
through
graph propagation and
this gives us an extraction of
with precision 65
to give you the details again this is on
the swde benchmark
and we can see that the precision is
lower
but we get a lot more
new attributes it used to be only four
or five attributes
and then now it is 10x and to show you
some examples
for nba player our seat
predicate is height weight and a team
that's what we have
in the see the knowledge graph and we
are able to identify new
attributes from the 10 mba player
websites about birth date birthplace
salary age experience position college
year drafted so on and so forth
we applied the same techniques on the 33
long tail movie websites and recall that
this purple line is our series
curve for preceding the yield
and now we have this green line for this
open ie
so comparing with closed information
extraction
now we added significant amount of
knowledge
for new predicates but on the other hand
the quality is lower and especially if
we look at
this line these are the extraction for
the new attributes we see that the curve
is still not in the best
shape and we still need to improve the
precision
so this technique now allows us
to extract unknown unknowns in other
words we do not
know this those attributes before but we
are able to extract it
so that is part of the iceberg
below the water
so the next clue is the visual patterns
on the web page so what do i mean
here uh i want to give you a quiz
i don't know how many people um in the
audience
understand korean and uh so this is a
web page
in korean uh i guess most of you haven't
seen it before
and for me i don't understand those
characters
and i don't understand what this webpage
is about
however let me ask you with this page
what part of the page represent
the topic of this web page
so i guess it is this this must
be the topic for this page that's
also can be considered as the name
of the main entity for this page
so what is a predicate for this
entity so there are quite a few
and this is one example
and what are the values for this
predicate
so this is one value another value these
are all values for this
attribute is there any other value
okay so this 1961 is likely to be
another value even though we may not
know what part is the attribute name
so for this totally new page for you
without understanding the domain without
understanding the language
without understanding any single token
you will be able to extract some
knowledge triples like this
representing at this part and
also some knowledge triples like this
even though you do not
know exactly what is the predicate
so this is what human beings are able to
do
and how can we uh teach
computers to do the same thing
and here the
clues are the visual patterns we do not
know exactly how we get
this um uh this uh
this decision regarding the extraction
but
that might come from the font color and
the size
of those texts and also the location
and the alignment so based on this
we developed zero shot service and
the goal is to enable ourselves to
extract
knowledge from totally new domains
and the key techniques is to use graph
neural network
to learn the representation for each
text
field and then we can decide
the relationships between the text field
according to the representations so
we achieved precision recall of 45
on totally new domains and this
is not high much lower than closed ie or
open ie
however if we just compare with the
baselines where we
identify particular patterns we have
similar precision
and our recall improved a lot
so here are the pr
curve for the swde benchmark
and recall that we have four dom domains
if we train the model on one domain and
look at the extraction from all of the
four domains
that is this blue line and
if we train one more train the model on
one domain
and extract knowledge from the other
three domains
that gives us the pr curve
as this orange line so it is slightly
lower
but on the other hand not much lower
and that gives us the whole iceberg
so we are able to extract the knowledge
for domains that we have zero
understanding before or from a page
where we do not necessarily know
all of the text all of the languages
okay so so far i have been showing you
the results
and you might be thinking yeah with this
clues
if we can do that this is cool but what
exactly
is the secret sauce and what exactly is
the technique
so here i want to just highlight our
technique
for this zero shot extraction i want to
call out my co-authors
so colin and prashant from amazon
and hana from udall
so the idea is this so as i said we will
apply dn
and so this is graph new net and so we
need a graph
and the graph is generated according to
the page layout
each note is a text field such as
ethan hawks and each edge represents
the relationships it could be horizontal
edges
representing the left and the right
relationship
it could be vertical edges representing
the up and down relationship
it could also about the dom
edges representing the dom siblings or
drum cousins in the dom tree
so uh with this we are able to build the
graph
and the idea is whatever we learned
about
this text of field can uh
be propagated into its
horizontal neighbor into its
vertical neighbor and also
to its dom neighbor
so for each text of field we look at two
different
kinds of features the first one is
textual features
this is birth embedding of the text
there this is also the idf score
because normally the attribute names
appear much more frequently on the
website
comparing with the attribute values and
also the text length normally if it is
very long string
it is less likely to be the attribute
name we also look at the visual features
such as the font size color
the text view dimensions whether this is
bold and aligned in italic so on and so
forth
so let me use this example to tell you
the learning process so this
is a small area on the web page
about smith college we see the
acceptance rate
as well as the tuition
so for each text field we
capture the visual features and textual
features
and generate representations for them
meanwhile we generate the page layout
graph and we
feed the two into a graph attention
network
this allows us to propagate the
information
among the neighboring text fields
and that generates the contextual
feature
for each text field
so the context feature will contain
the features of the node itself as well
as the neighbors
so now to train the
extraction model for closed ie
our goal is to decide for each text of
field
which relation it is
corresponding to so for example for this
53 thousand dollars
we take all of the visual textual
and contextual features and feed it
into a multi-class classifier and then
we decide
okay this is a value of the
relation tuition
and then for open ie the idea is that
we take two text fields for example
tuition and the 53 000 and
for each text of field again we will
take the three
representations in addition we will
compare them pairwise and generate some
pairwise features
such as the alignment features and
we feed all of this into a binary
classifier
to decide whether or not this
is um uh
predicate value or attribute value pairs
so this is yes no decision binary
decision
we do pre-training on some simplified
ie tasks for each text field we
do three-way classification to decide if
that is a relation string
or an object string or some other
strings
it could be totally irrelevant to any
knowledge triples
and then we freeze the weights
of the graph neuranet and then train the
extraction layer on top of it
so that gives us the model
and the results we have just the same
okay are we there yet
so we have seen all of the different
models for information extraction
and we see that unfortunately the
extraction quality jobs from 90 percent
to 60 percent to 40 percent
and when we want to launch something in
industry it has to be at least a 90
percent precision
so how can we improve the extraction
precision to above 90 percent
and here one idea is to combine
zero-shot learning with distance
supervision
also inspired by bird embedding
we wonder if we could learn the
representations
for semi-structured data such that
we can use the representations to
support
different applications not only the
extraction
application but also question answering
search
or fact validation
so so far this is about extraction so
some of you might have
been already thinking if i get
open ie extraction from this about a
movie director and from this about movie
directed by
how can i put all of them together how
can i decide if director
and directed by are representing the
same relationship
so this is very important for open ie
given the time i don't want to
talk too much about it and you are
welcome to
read our papers open ki
to solve this problem but the problem is
not fully solved
and as you can see the mean average
precision
is still quite low so there is still
room to improve to get good results
and here i just um for some
entertainment for this long talk
i would like to show you this um cool
animation where for every predicate
extracted from each uh source
we generate the representation of the
the predicate and then we can use the
representation to decide whether they
are the same
predicate we see some kind of
clusters but on the other hand we see
that film
director film writer film even film
actor
there are a lot of overlaps because
oftentimes one person
is both director and writer of a movie
so the next thing is we talked about
linking the relations the next thing
naturally
is how to link the entities how can we
decide if these two
are the same person and this is entity
link
linkage the first technique i mentioned
at the beginning of the talk and
as i said we are able to
solve this problem with very high
precision
recall for two sources but
when we come to web extraction we have
two challenges the first challenge is we
could have
thousands of different types and how can
we train
models for different types of entities
movies
songs and tv shows and the broadway
shows etc
how can we link them and
the second challenge is we could have
millions of sources
and i want to spend a little bit of time
to tell you why this is hard
why we can train the model for two
sources but not for millions of sources
this is because the different sources
have very different distributions
and we could train a model that
does very well to connect music brings
with another source let's say disc
cox but when we apply the same model
on last dot film for whatever reason
if they miss the artist's information
the model could
perform very badly
and we did some initial study
we trained the model on seven sources
and here we report the results on four
of the sources
for track artist album you can see the
entity linkage
prauc the area under the pr
curve is quite high above 0.9
but on the other hand if we train on
three sources
and apply the model on the rest of the
four sources
you see this prauc dropped significantly
and so the question is we won't be able
to get the training data from so many
different websites
and how can we train one model that
applies
everywhere
okay so several takeaways we aim at
harvesting knowledge from all
semi-structured data on the web and
we aim at achieving both high accuracy
and also we are open so we hopefully
could
extract unknown unknowns and there
are still a lot of research problems to
solve
to really get there and i would like to
advocate for two benchmark data sets
the first one is an extended
swde benchmark so swd
is the benchmark i mentioned and we
significantly
extended the benchmark with a lot of
annotations on new attributes
and the second one is di to kg data
integration to knowledge graph
this is a challenge benchmark and
it gives you data set not only to
play with knowledge extraction but also
about knowledge alignment knowledge
integration
so with that i'd like to thank you very
much for listening
and i'd love to answer questions